So first,
to be able to talk about generalization.
It helps to think about
states as actually being
collections of features instead
of just unanalyzed blobs.
>> So we're no longer to refer to
states as state 17 and state 19?
>> We can.
But I think it's helpful actually to
give them additional information like
these features.
So here's a concrete example to
make this, try to make some sense.
Do you remember our taxi problem
that we talked about before?
>> How could I forget.
>> In this particular environment,
there was something like, I don't know,
500 states and in standard q learning
type approaches, we would just think of
all those different states as being
completely different from one another.
But we can also imagine tagging each of
the states with some particular value.
Like whether or not well,
we don't really have fuel when we talked
about it, but whether we're low on fuel.
What is the X coordinate of
the taxi cab, this thing here.
What's the Y coordinate the taxi cab?
Is the taxi cab currently near a wall?
Say to the you know to some direction,
north, south, east, west.
Each of these different features
give us a little bit of a handle on
the states and
how they relate to each other right.
So if we have this state that we've got
right here and we say move the passenger
to some other position,
we're still in a related state.
The taxi hasn't moved and it would be
nice to be able to capture that and so
this notion of features
gives us that idea.
Does that makes sense?
>> So that's a lot like how we
talked about machine learning and
supervised learning in our
other machine learning class.
>> Exactly.
Yeah, in fact we had words for
these things.
We talked about the,
boy what were those words?
It's sort of the notion that
different machine learning
representations cause different
things to be similar to each other.
>> Right.
And there are lots of different ways
that we could represent the state space
other than whatever
the different 500 states are.
You have some of them up here, but
we could have the coordinates of
where the passenger is, not just
the coordinates of where the taxi is.
We could have things represented and
sort of an egocentric way.
What's the, I don't know, Manhattan
distance between a passenger and
where the passenger wants to end up.
There are all kinds of things that we
could the ways we could describe things
and some of those things
make some states look
more similar than other
representations would.
>> I think I remember the term.
I think it was inductive bias.
>> Inductive bias was something that
referred to the way algorithms preferred
one solution over another.
>> But I think you're right, though,
because different features
sort of create different
kind of inductive biases by making
some states look more similar.
So, for example,
if we had this egocentric notion of how
far away a person is from a taxi,
then so
long as a person is say two steps
away from a taxi, any state where
a person is two steps away from a taxi
looks the same or looks very similar.
In fact, if you look at this one you
have now if you just drew that right
the red circle is close
to the orange square.
If you were to move
both the red circle and
the orange square up, those two states
would still be very similar because
they're still two away from one
another or have two in between them.
But even though I don't move the red
circle, if I take the orange square and
move it to the right, then that's less
similar because they're farther apart.
>> Okay, and they were ignoring
walls the way he described it right?
>> Right, I'm ignoring walls.
>> We move both of these up by two
we're so yeah we're two apart but
it does feel kind of different
to go around the walls.
>> And if it's different or
not different depends upon
the state features that you use.
>> Okay do we have a name for that or.
Is inductive bias an okay stand in?
>> It's a representation, right?
It's a representation.
Some representations are better for
some things than others and
you can learn differently depending
upon which features you choose.
>> Okay.
>> For example, here's a great feature.
For every state,
here's the set of actions you
should take to accomplish the goal.
That's one representation that
makes learning really easy.
>> Yes, good point.
So let's talk about what we're
actually going to learn.
>> Okay.